[Music]
foreign
he either let go of him or do a real pin
same acceleration
[Music]
again a real pin
or let go of him hi
[Music]
arm the arm the arm the arms the arm is
isolated take the arm
foreign
clear the line
push another acceleration throw
same thing that's an acceleration
through
let's say this Suzuki is fine
okay
and here's the mat
and usually
what you were doing
is you're kind of let's say their center
of gravity is here
you're you're accelerating it
in One Direction so this is the the head
there's the nose you accelerate it to
the front
so you get like a little tilt maybe
you're here
and then you accelerate
that center of gravity
and then what happens is that the
UK is it gets lazy
and it's more of a convenience so
it's a little more difficult to get
their feet back underneath
so they get that upright posture again
and then but so what they do instead is
they leave their feet there and they let
just
from from their will to leave their feet
there
eventually this acceleration of this
center of gravity here they just decide
for a convenience sake to take a
topsy-turvy effect
two things so they they did it because
as you pay attention
in the acceleration from here you get
some little tilt going there is no
topsy-turvy energy in the throat there's
no energy working on the head and no
energy working on the feet
and then at the same time
there's no uh
let's say spiraling of this of the
center through space the center is still
just traveling sagittably across the mat
it's it itself is not turning
okay
we'll do that last one you did okay so
we're gonna come around here here is
that tilt of your body can you see okay
and then you just accelerate
you see that
yeah
okay now use your athleticism that we
train and just run out of it
[Music]
every single time
so somewhere
I have to start to add
differences so instead of cutting here
I'm going to start to rotate this
go back
and as I do that my body is going to go
this way you feel that
way
so not here
so here is the top
Force working on your head okay
and here is
the bottom Force
working
on your leg
so after I do the chikai 10
and I cut down on your hand that's the
top force on your head and in my base
in the IDI miyashi is the bottom
force on your
feet so now I actually have
a throat not it's convenient for hookah
not to run
okay now I gotta add
this thing okay so I'm going to rotate
your Center and that's why I don't cut
straight down
but you're going to go
I'll do it without baby you're going to
go this way
[Music]
and maybe if you want to see over here
my hands not gonna go
here
my hand is going to go this way
oh
so if we say run out of it
why can't you run off
so of course in Naga is here
close you now again
here
there's not on my question
into that leg
okay
foreign
[Music]
there you go that's the pattern
s
thank you
you guys both did that one
okay hey
and then you go in this way
okay
with your adhesion hey not your
and you don't have to go here
in the law you have his body
we're going to project you it's the API
okay still try to stand up
you think I stand up
okay
and then try not to go backwards okay
try not to go back right
in Dubai
foreign
[Music]
with you
okay okay
[Music]
pour over the top
fingers down
[Music]
through the center from there
foreign
[Music]
acceleration throw
foreign
don't go off between reps when you're
when you're knocking you got four reps
to stay in a communion with him even
when you're not touching him you keep
going egocentric after each throw you
want to break you you clear you
disengage from the engagement altogether
okay let's go okay
thank you
foreign
don't push forward right
relax
just relax
let me go don't move don't move hey
don't move
your arms
right you're pretty much standing
straight up can you see that okay make a
fighting stance with your hands look
okay so you went like this and you got
him down then you bring them back to
that face he's perfectly upright again
okay you have to tilt him and he's gonna
he's gonna go knock back
this way
[Music]
good
morning
this way
okay and then what am I going to do step
behind my leg that's right because this
is just an acceleration throw step out
of it
the bottom here is your time oh
there you go
hello
[Music]
so here is one part of the Topsy Turvy
and here is the other part
and then don't don't make him go
that way
start to spin him let's lift this start
to spin him
got it hi
shhh
HH
[Music]
a
you make him spin
thank you
stop waiting on the line
[Music]
you
foreign
[Music]
then I go now
then on the line okay
already
I feel all of that energy that I'm gonna
feel I feel already in my body my body's
matters that it has energy so I moved
and moved out the line
foreign
make it more meditative
don't keep going in and out we don't do
salsanely
okay stay in it
foreign
all right so that throws me
dealt with so far
here's my dude
okay
we do this kind of only one only working
on the top part
so it ends up being like this
and he starts to go past the Apex of no
return into a roll but only because he
left his feet there
but if we're doing it right
there is there is a force
on the head
and there is a force on the feet
and then due to
those two forces spiraling themselves
through space there is this going on on
his body okay he's turning around it
once is it's not that his body goes like
this it's it as his body's gone it's
turning okay
that is one kind of throw
did you have koku Nagin
kokunaga is working through something a
little different
okay you do use Kokyo on all of those
throws but kokunaga is a little
different
here I'm not going to have
a visible Force
either
I either don't have it here
or I don't have it here
in other words there's not two forces
working topsy-turvy okay it's either one
or the other
where does the topsy-turvy effect come
from
it comes from your energy what you did
with your energy okay
so
what is key
is I'll do something let's say we'll
take the one that you just did
there's going to be
a force here
but there's no Force here
I'm not having my body there okay but
as I continue to work this part as I
continue to spin the technique
your foot in its effort to gain balance
is going to try to move back under your
basis support so I'm going to work on
that eventually your body is going to
tilt
and then you're gonna try to put your
foot underneath your base of support so
that your back standing upright okay
once you put that foot down
wherever you let's say you put it here
okay once you put that foot down I
continue this Force going
and now
I will project
this center that is spinning I will
project it
out
okay so if you look at it from the top
here let's say that's your basis support
right
and
you're tilted
I'm going to keep bringing this part
over here and I'm going to make the
whole base of support move out here
I made that go out there how by making
your Center go out that way
okay and then that way
you can't keep stepping underneath your
basic support because your basic support
moved in the opposite direction from
where you were trying to replace it
underneath your line of gravity
okay
so for example if I do that if the
technique you did and you could run out
of that
foreign
but if I cook you project I cut down
here and this Coq projection I'll leave
that hand off this Coq projection is
going that way
so you have this time coming around you
and then this hand going that way
so you now have an x pattern but it's
not with my body not um for example here
the x pattern was my like my hand going
this way and my stands going this way
okay
this time
this handle here
this way this handle that way and you
have the Xbox
so if you want to know what to look for
you have to film Luke yeah
on an acceleration roll where UK decides
to just roll
his rule goes right where his foot is
now that's just roll here he's right
there
[Music]
his foot will always go right into the
roll
[Music]
his foot as I said is going to be the
launching pad for his Center and he
thought okay did you okay so your your
tattoo goes any any old way
any any old way
it's not like this though
keep projecting
even here you can do it okay
let's go
you got a ground you got to be able to
uh let his energy through you otherwise
it'll displace you
you bounce off of him
[Music]
foreign
age
I showed you you can do chikaiten
without the x pattern the external x
pattern
do you remember the last technique I
showed okay so you can do all all you
can do all of these so I can do things
and this is a physical
other toxic survey you understand oh but
you can still do
same X just like you're gonna do
passionate Noggin right we kind of
trying to do it what you guys are doing
yeah you can still do
you see the difference okay
[Music]
foreign
first three not last one good
there you go
for Jack
try to hold your balance okay
good
foreign
[Music]
don't give them back you see he went
right back to standing upright
okay so Kazuki
uh the first thing you do in if you do
what okay and you answer is you want to
start these spiraling fighting geometry
okay so that's why you don't do this
the second if I designate him okay got
it then that's 12
I understand that six
okay just like uh I'm walking and that
guy's a hold on I already started
spiraling do you understand without so
do you wanna I don't stay at six right
away I start moving this way
this way
this way I go to one of the corners okay
to get him to have to turn so when do I
go not before he starts
as he starts going you see I already
turned
okay and what that's going to do is this
is going to set up
kazushi kazushi let's understand kazushi
I want his spine to tilt okay I don't
want him upright like this that is why
you don't ever do
this and then he throws
there should never be a time Once We
Touch where he's standing straight up
okay uh it doesn't let's say I'm gonna
do is
he wants to turn inside turn this way
you don't even know how to do it
you say and look she again Let's ignore
the grip
he's got Perfect Balance again
okay he should he should never be
allowed to stand straight up or going
back to the other technique we're
showing you're here and then you bring
them block up no
he must always be tilty
so when I go to the inside and he takes
that turn towards me you see he's going
to I Can Begin the tilting of his body
much easier so
first rule kazushi starts before you
touch
okay
second rule
kazushi has his fine tilting
it's never upright
and because you see is continuous to the
throw so it never tilts then goes
upright and then tilts again it doesn't
happen okay
and then the way that I have it tilt is
through the
Center to Center or the I keep going in
your body okay so I'm not only in his
arms I'm not in his arms I'm in his body
in his body
just like here I'm not only in his arms
it's right here it is right
it is mine so I go down it's his body
goes down when I go through project his
Center his Center is this time you catch
it
you see it's in his body okay so I'm
gonna
start your tilting
but it has to be
from where you're touching me into your
Center okay so I'm going to do uh
tenshinaga you guys are doing a lot of
attention now okay so I move at you but
look I sidestep
s I'm not gonna wait here
and then go out
are you going to sidestep
and we'll do it over here oh look he's
tilting you see and again uh look
notches here pulling his skin suit down
okay I I'm in in him
oh I move I do the yin yield there's the
Tilt stop there okay
when I'm doing intentionally go back one
step
is first uh IQ adhesion is in his palms
and I passed the eye cohesion to this
arm and his neck
okay so you're going to take this away
and now this is moving him
we'll do it again right here Sean
I move towards him once he engages
I cleared a line and now I get his body
at touch
I go to the tilts and now I'm here now
I'm here okay and now you do it those X
patterns that you want
the ex pattern so his head's gonna go
that way as I do the X pop
that way
he never was blocked off
or no could do it as a kokunagi
okay let's skip